هذا وقد يحتلت التجارب الصاروخيه الكوريه
الشماليه الحيز الاكبر من اعمال القمه
اليابانيه الكوريه الجنوبيه في طوكيو وهي
اول قمه بين البلدين منذ اثنتي عشره عاما
واتفقت الدولتان الحليفتان للولايات
المتحده على مشاركه التتبع اللحظي لاطلاق
الصواريخ الكوريه الشماليه وتعاهدت بتعزيز
تعزيز اكبر في مجال التعاون العسكري وفي
اول خدمه ثنائيه بين البلدين منذ 12 عاما
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الياباني عن اعاده
كوريا الجنوبيه الى القائمه البيضاء للدول
التي تحظى بمعامله تفضيليه فيما يتعلق
بالتصدير ورفع القيود عن تصدير التقنيات
العاليه اليها من جهته قال رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه ان زيارته تفتح صفحه جديده في
العلاقات بين البلدين الجارين كما تم
الاعلان عن سحب الدعوه القضائيه التي رف
عتها بلاده ضد اليابان في منظمه التجاره
العالميه